here's a fun geometry problem in
triangle ABC the midpoint of a b is D
the midpoint of b c is e the midpoint of
b e is f and the area of triangle DCF is
63. what is the area of triangle ABC to
get started suppose triangle dbf has
area equal to X then since b f is equal
to Fe and triangle d f e has the same
height as triangle dbf DFE also has area
equaled X by the same principle this
entire triangle has area equal to 2X and
b e is equal to EC so triangle DEC has
area equal to 2x using the principle one
more time since BD is equal to 80
triangle ADC has area equal to 4X we
know that triangle DFC has area equal to
63 so 3x equals 63 x is equal to 21. the
entire triangle ABC has area equal to 8X
and that means the area of triangle ABC
equals 168.